There's certain conversations that those of us who do not live on farms get into with people who do live on farms, where you know, as somebody from the city or the suburbs, that the farm person that you're talking to is just thinking, you are so naive. Often these conversations have to do with animals and their deaths. Take this example. The woman who started our program's website, Elizabeth Meister, was at the annual exhibition run by the American Poultry Association in Columbus, Ohio. And here she is, standing in a room with 12,000 chickens. And she gets into a conversation with an 11-year-old girl.
在我们这些不住在农场的人与那些住在农场的人之间，会产生一些特定的对话，作为城市或郊区来的人，你知道，你交谈的那位农场人士心里在想：你真是太天真了。这些对话通常与动物及其死亡有关。举个例子，负责我们节目网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特，当时正在俄亥俄州哥伦布市参加美国禽业博览会。她站在一个养了12000只鸡的房间里，和一个11岁的小女孩聊了起来。
I've only been in poultry and water fowl for a year. I'm more into water fowl.
我进入家禽和水禽行业才一年。我更喜欢水禽。
This is Kamiko Overs from Bliss, New York, who was at the convention to show some of her chickens.
这是来自纽约州布利斯市的卡米科·奥弗斯，她来参加展会是为了展示她的一些鸡。
So do your friends think it's weird? Do they think it's strange that you show chickens and stuff?
那你的朋友觉得这很奇怪吗？他们觉得你展示鸡之类的东西很奇怪吗？
No, because a lot of people show. They'll either be showing pigs or cows or rabbits, or something like that. A lot of people at our school show different things.
不，因为很多人都参加展示。他们要么展示猪、牛或兔子之类的东西。我们学校很多人展示各种不同的东西。
Kamiko and Elizabeth talked for a while. And then Elizabeth tried very, very gently to ask a question that was on her mind.
卡米科和伊丽莎白聊了一会儿。然后，伊丽莎白非常、非常温和地试着问了一个她心里想的问题。
This is sort of a hard question for me to ask, but do you ever eat them?
对我来说，这个问题有点难以启齿，但你吃过它们吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我吃。
You do?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And does it make your really sad? I mean, do you raise these chickens from little chicks?
那你不会感到很难过吗？我是说，这些鸡是你从小鸡开始养大的吗？
Yeah, we hatch them out. And then-- yep. We get them right from the hen, and we eat them a lot. We do raise a lot for feeding.
是的，我们把它们孵化出来。然后——是的。我们直接从母鸡那里得到它们，而且我们经常吃它们。我们确实养了很多用于食用。
And so when you're cooking up this chicken that you've raised from being a little chick, do you feel a little bit guilty that you're eating this chicken?
所以，当你烹饪这只你从小鸡开始养大的鸡时，你会因为吃了这只鸡而感到一点内疚吗？
No.
不会。
Do you ever eat the chickens that you show?
你会吃你展示的那些鸡吗？
If they're no good for show. The losers, yeah.
如果它们不适合参展的话。失败者，是的，会吃。
Kamiko's untroubled by this. If a bird has bad feathers or a lopsided comb, it might be a nice bird, but if it's not going to win competitions, you eat it. That's life. Those of us who don't live on farms, we tend to divide animals often into those we love and those we eat. In Kamiko's world, there isn't such a hard line separating the two. You can get to know a bird on an up close, one-to-one basis, and still eat it.
卡米科对此并不困扰。如果一只鸟羽毛不好或鸡冠歪斜，它可能是一只不错的鸟，但如果它赢不了比赛，你就吃了它。这就是生活。我们这些不住在农场的人，倾向于把动物分成我们喜爱的和我们食用的。在卡米科的世界里，这两者之间没有那么明确的界限。你可以近距离、一对一地了解一只鸟，同时依然吃掉它。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. And today, during this period between Thanksgiving and Christmas, the highest poultry consumption time of the year in these United States, we bring you a program about poultry, our Poultry Slam, stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, birds of all kinds, and our relationships with them.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在感恩节和圣诞节之间的这段时期，也就是美国一年中家禽消费量最高的时期，我们为您带来一期关于家禽的节目——我们的“禽类大放送”，讲述鸡、火鸡、鸭子等各类鸟类，以及我们与它们之间的关系。
Poultry Slams have been a not-quite annual tradition on our show around this time of year. And putting together this year's program, a very few particular ideas and questions kept coming up in story after story, without us ever intending for it to happen that way. A lot of this year's show has turned into a kind of referendum about where you draw the line between friend and food.
“禽类大放送”是我们节目在每年这个时候不完全算作年度传统的特别节目。在筹备今年的节目时，一些特定的想法和问题在故事中不断浮现，而我们从没打算让它变成这样。今年的节目很大程度上演变成了一种关于如何在朋友和食物之间划清界限的全民公投。
Act one of today's show, Still Life With Chicken. Food writer Jonathan Gold tells what it's like to pan fry a chicken, with a live chicken watching you the entire time. Act two, Last Meal. When the President of France, Francois Mitterrand, knew he was about to die, he decided that the very last food to cross his lips would be poultry, a tiny bird that is actually illegal to eat in France, a bird that by tradition is eaten with a napkin covering your head. Act three, Chicken Diva. Jack Hitt tells the story of a chicken opera complete with, yes, avian supernumeraries. Act four, The Meaning of a Bird. David Rakoff explains how his life was changed in a single evening in a room full of 5,000 chickens. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕，“静物与鸡”。美食作家乔纳森·戈尔德讲述了在活鸡注视下煎鸡肉是什么感觉。第二幕，“最后的晚餐”。当法国总统弗朗索瓦·密特朗知道自己即将去世时，他决定自己口中品尝的最后一种食物将是禽肉，一种在法国实际上是非法食用的微小鸟类，一种传统上必须用餐巾盖住头才能食用的鸟。第三幕，“鸡肉天后”。杰克·希特讲述了一个鸡肉歌剧的故事，当然，还有禽类群众演员。第四幕，“鸟的意义”。大卫·拉科夫讲述了他的生活是如何在一个满是5000只鸡的房间里度过的一个晚上而彻底改变的。请继续收听。
Act One, Still Life With Chicken. It was an accident that Jonathan ended up living with a chicken. He wasn't living the kind of life one usually associates with chickens.
第一幕，静物与鸡。乔纳森最终与一只鸡生活在一起纯属意外。他当时的生活方式通常与鸡没什么关联。
This was during the period when I considered myself to be a performance artist of sorts, a naked performance artist to be specific.
那是在我自认为是某种表演艺术家的时期，具体来说，是一位裸体行为艺术家。
These days, Jonathan Gold is a food writer in Los Angeles. This all happened 15 years ago. He was putting together a performance. He had a PA system which could put out the requisite amount of annoying feedback sound at high decibels. He had the two full bottles of Glade American Beauty Air Freshener, which he would spray in their entirety in the performance space. And he had a live chicken, which he bought the day before the performance in one of those Chinese poultry markets in Los Angeles. And it comes the day of the show. An audience gathers in a darkened warehouse in West LA.
如今，乔纳森·戈尔德是洛杉矶的一位美食作家。这一切发生在15年前。他当时正在筹备一场表演。他有一个音响系统，可以以高分贝输出所需数量的恼人反馈音。他有两整瓶“Glade”牌美国佳丽空气清新剂，他会在表演空间里全部喷完。他还有一只活鸡，是他表演前一天在洛杉矶的华人禽类市场买的。演出当天到了。观众聚集在西洛杉矶一个漆黑的仓库里。
I don't know if you've been to a lot of performance art, but this was really typical of the stuff that was going on in the period. And I showed up. And I was naked. And I was carrying a machete. And I was blindfolded. And I stood in the middle of this pile of supermarket chickens, the broilers that you buy. And the chicken that I had bought was tethered to a three-foot rope around me. And I hacked up and down blindly with the machete.
我不知道你是否看过很多行为艺术，但这在当时非常典型。我出场了。我是裸体的。我拿着一把大砍刀。我被蒙住了眼睛。我站在一堆超市鸡（就是你们买的那种肉鸡）中间。我买的那只鸡用一根三英尺长的绳子拴在我的身边。我盲目地挥舞着砍刀，上下乱砍。
Toward the chicken, or just in general?
是朝着鸡砍，还是随便乱砍？
Well, I was blindfolded, so I didn't know if it was towards the chicken or not.
嗯，我蒙着眼睛，所以我不知道是否是朝着鸡砍的。
And I had fully intended that, in fact, I would kill the chicken in the midst of this performance. But chickens aren't that stupid. And this chicken wanted no part of the machete. It stayed at the end of its rope the entire time, apparently. And after 10 minutes, when I was completely exhausted, I fell to a heap. And everybody left. And the performance was over.
我确实打算在表演中杀掉那只鸡。但鸡没那么笨。那只鸡一点也不想参与砍刀的表演。它显然全程都待在绳子的另一端。10分钟后，我筋疲力尽，倒成了一堆。然后大家都离开了。表演结束了。
I don't know if you've stuck around after an art performance. But the few minutes after an art performance are some of the most depressing in the world.
我不知道你在艺术表演结束后是否留下来过。但在艺术表演结束后的那几分钟，是世界上最压抑的时刻之一。
How so?
怎么讲？
You've done your wad. You've done your bit for art, which has either worked or it hasn't. But you're sitting there. You're covered with chicken effluvia, in my case. It stinks to high hell. Everybody's gone. And you've got to clean up. And you're naked. It's really not a pretty picture.
你已经拼尽全力了。你为艺术贡献了自己，无论是否成功。但你坐在那儿。就我而言，我身上沾满了鸡的排泄物。臭得要命。所有人都走了。你还得清理现场。而且你还是裸体的。这画面真的不太美观。
So Jonathan cleaned up. And when he was done, he had a chicken. And he didn't feel like he could kill the chicken. Destiny had brought them together. He felt like he could not turn his back. He says it was the same as if a kitten shows up on your back door, scratching and lonely and needy. So he took the chicken home. And in doing that, he stumbled across that thin, thin line that separates food items on the one hand, from pets on the other, that divides the animals we eat from the animals we love.
所以乔纳森清理了现场。当他完成时，他手里还有一只鸡。他觉得他下不去手杀掉这只鸡。命运让他们走到了一起。他觉得他不能背弃它。他说这就像如果你后门出现了一只小猫，抓着门，孤独而需要帮助，也是一样的。于是他把鸡带回了家。在这样做的时候，他偶然跨越了那条极其细微的界限，那条将宠物与食物区分开来的界限，将我们食用的动物与我们喜爱的动物分开的界限。
So I get home, and I have this chicken. And I don't know what to do with it. So I spread out some newspaper on the top of my refrigerator. And I put the chicken up there. I get a can of Green Giant brand niblets from under the counter. And I open it. And I put it in a little bowl for the chicken. And I give the chicken a little water. And the chicken's on top of my refrigerator.
我回到家，带回了这只鸡。我不知道该拿它怎么办。于是我在冰箱顶上铺了一些报纸。我把鸡放在上面。我从柜台下拿出一罐“绿巨人”牌玉米粒。我打开它。我把它放在一个小碗里给鸡吃。我就给鸡喂了点水。这只鸡就待在我的冰箱顶上。
Because you think chickens eat corn. You had read that or something. And that was the available corn.
因为你以为鸡吃玉米。你可能读到过或者之类的。那是当时手边有的玉米。
That was the available corn. I wish I had thought better of the niblets idea.
那是当时手边有的玉米。我真希望自己当初能对玉米粒这个想法三思。
Why?
为什么？
Because, in fact, if you're buying three or four cans of niblets a day, which is what the chicken ate, and you're existing on almost nothing, which I was, then your niblet bill turns out to be some two-figure percentage of your total income each week. I mean, if you could imagine living on $50 a week, but $10 of it goes for niblets. It's just hard to justify an expense like that.
因为事实上，如果你一天买三四罐玉米粒，这就是这只鸡的食量，而你当时几乎一无所有，像我当时那样，那么你的玉米粒账单每周会占到你总收入的两位数百分比。我是说，如果你能想象每周靠50美元生活，其中10美元却花在玉米粒上。这种开销真的很难说服自己。
Though at the remove of 15 years, I think I can probably safely admit to you now that one of the reasons that I stuck with niblets is because I liked saying the word niblets so much. And this gave me the excuse to use a word like niblet in general conversation several times a day. Usually it just doesn't come up. And the chicken stayed there on top of my refrigerator for a long time. Months, six months, I think.
尽管15年过去了，我想我现在大概可以坦白告诉你，我坚持买玉米粒的原因之一是因为我太喜欢说“玉米粒”这个词了。这给了我一个在日常对话中每天多次使用“玉米粒”这个词的借口。通常它根本不会出现。这只鸡在我的冰箱顶上待了很长时间。几个月，我想有六个月。
This is like a one-room apartment?
这就像是一个单间公寓吗？
A two-room apartment. I had a kitchen and a bedroom. So I didn't have to look at the chicken when I was sleeping. Though I did have to look at it when I was cooking.
一个两居室公寓。我有一个厨房和一个卧室。所以我睡觉时不用看着那只鸡。虽然我做饭时不得不看着它。
Did you ever cook chicken?
你有没有做过鸡肉吃？
Of course I cooked chicken.
我当然做过鸡肉。
Didn't you feel intensely disloyal?
你不觉得这太不忠诚了吗？
No. I felt no particular loyalty to this chicken. I don't know if you've ever had chickens, but you don't pet chickens. Chickens don't really like you to pet them. And you don't hold them. There's really no love that you feel for a chicken in your life, I don't think.
不。我对这只鸡没有特别的忠诚感。我不知道你有没有养过鸡，但你不会去抚摸鸡。鸡其实并不喜欢你摸它们。而且你不会抱着它们。我不认为生活中你对鸡会有什么爱意。
But yet you kept the chicken.
但你还是留下了这只鸡。
I kept the chicken. Because I couldn't bear to do anything else. I mean, it's not like I could have carried it out onto Pico Boulevard and said, "be free, little chicken, be free."
我留下了它。因为我无法忍受做其他任何事情。我是说，我总不能把它带到皮科大道上说：“走吧，小鸡，获得自由吧。”
Did you give the chicken a name?
你给它起名字了吗？
I never named the chicken. When I referred to the chicken in public, I always called it the hen.
我从来没给它起过名字。在公共场合提到它时，我总是叫它“那只母鸡”。
How did you not name it? It was a creature in your house.
你竟然没给它起名字？它可是你屋里的一个生物。
The chicken always seemed temporary. It never occurred to me that I might have the chicken as long as six months. The chicken always seemed like something that I would have for just a couple days.
那只鸡总是显得很临时。我从未想过我会养这只鸡长达六个月。这只鸡看起来总像是那种我只会养几天就没了的东西。
And then what did you think was going to happen?
那你当时觉得会发生什么？
I guess A, I thought about the chicken expiring. B, I have to admit that there was a possibility that someday I would actually cook the chicken. I went through a lot of chicken recipes, hundreds and hundreds of chicken recipes.
我想A，我考虑过这只鸡可能会老死。B，我不得不承认有一天我确实可能会把这只鸡做成菜。我查阅了大量的鸡肉食谱，成百上千个。
Thinking maybe this will be the recipe for my niblet-fed chicken?
心想也许这就是我那只吃玉米粒长大的鸡的食谱？
Exactly.
正是如此。
Possibly, I have to say, the most delicious chicken that you could ever eat because of those niblets.
我不得不说，那可能是你吃过的最美味的鸡肉，因为吃了那些玉米粒。
You can't buy niblet-fed chicken, for love or money, I don't think. I'm not sure that a recipe existed that would have lived up to the fact of the chicken, this animal who you have come to know on fairly intimate terms and who you have raised and who you have put a certain amount of emotion into.
我想，无论花多少钱或出于什么理由，你都买不到这种吃玉米粒长大的鸡。我不确定是否存在一份食谱能配得上这只鸡的真实身份，毕竟这只动物你已经相当了解，亲自喂养，并且投入了一定的情感。
A chicken, if I might say, who has seen you naked.
一只见过你裸体的鸡，恕我直言。
The chicken did see me naked, damn it.
该死的，它确实见过我裸体。
The fact is we need food to be just food. And as soon as it becomes a living thing-- especially if we're city people, we're not used to the conversion of living things into our food-- it's hard to handle without thinking it has to be bigger than food, without wanting to make it ritualized or something bigger than food.
事实上，我们需要食物仅仅是食物。而一旦它变成了一个活物——特别是如果像我们这种城市人，我们不习惯将活物转化为我们的食物——这就很难处理，我们总觉得它必须比食物更重要，总想通过某种仪式让它变得不同寻常。
Exactly. Can I tell you a small story?
没错。我可以讲一个小故事吗？
Yeah, of course.
当然可以。
A few weeks ago, I was in this Korean restaurant in Koreatown in Los Angeles. It was this place called the Living Fish Center that I'd always wanted to go, because the name of it was so splendid. Living Fish Center. I imagined some sort of vast vivarium where Flipper was jumping through hoops and stuff. And I go in there, and of course it's just a crummy Korean restaurant. I mean, it's not that clean. And there are tanks and stuff, but I don't know what to order.
几周前，我在洛杉矶韩国城的一家韩国餐馆。那地方叫“活鱼中心”，我一直想去，因为名字太炫酷了。活鱼中心。我想象着那是一个巨大的饲养场，海豚在跳圈之类的。我进去了，当然，它只是一家破旧的韩国餐馆。我是说，不太干净。里面有鱼缸什么的，但我不知道该点什么。
So I order a fish soup, because it looks like they have a small fish soup specialty on the menu. And it comes. And it's just really strong smelling and not that great. And I try squid, fried with bean sauce and onions, which wasn't that happening. And I'm about to give up and pay the check, and go home with a vast table filled with uneaten stuff, and it suddenly occurs to me what the specialty of the restaurant is.
所以我点了一份鱼汤，因为菜单上看起来有一种小型鱼汤特产。端上来了。味道非常冲，并不怎么好。我还试了鱿鱼，用豆酱和洋葱炒的，也不怎么样。我正准备放弃结账，带着满满一桌没吃完的菜回家，突然我意识到这家餐馆的招牌菜是什么了。
And I wave the waitress over. And I tell her that I'd like a prawn. And she is puzzled. She didn't expect me to ask for a prawn. But I repeat my question. And she shrugs and goes and tells the sushi chef. And he goes to one side of the restaurant, and he climbs on this chair, this ordinary folding chair. And he reaches into this long tank that's running just below the ceiling.
我叫过服务员，告诉她我想要一只对虾。她很困惑。她没想到我会点对虾。但我重复了一遍。她耸耸肩，去告诉了寿司厨师。他走到餐馆的一边，爬上一把普通的折叠椅。他伸手够向天花板下方的一条长鱼缸。
And he wiggles his fingers in the water. When he wiggles the fingers, the prawns just become enraged. And they start nipping at his fingers. And they start attacking him. And he picks out a couple of the liveliest ones and brings them back to his counter, and-- without washing his hands, mind you-- just makes a few motions over it. And a couple seconds later, the waitress comes over with the prawns on this huge mound of ice.
他在水里摆动手指。当他摆动手指时，那些对虾变得暴躁起来。它们开始咬他的手指。它们开始攻击他。他挑出几只最活泼的，带回柜台，然后——注意，他没洗手——只是在上面挥了几下。几秒钟后，服务员端着放在巨大冰堆上的对虾走了过来。
Now, what he'd done is he'd taken off the exoskeleton. Essentially the head was intact, and that little part of the tail that is always on prawns is still there. But the middle part is naked, like a grub. And I picked up the prawn with my chopsticks. And it was not dead, this prawn. It was extremely alive. And it was wiggling its legs, and it was wiggling its antennas, and its eyes were swiveling madly on its eye stalk.
他已经去掉了外骨架。基本上头是完整的，虾尾那部分还在。但中间部分是赤裸的，像个幼虫。我用筷子夹起那只虾。它还没死，这只虾。它极其活跃。它的腿在动，触角在动，眼睛在眼柄上疯狂地旋转。
And it was looking back at me, seeing me as actually the predator, the creature that was going to eat it. And that was a really freakish moment. Because as much stuff as I eat, and as low as I eat on the food chain, and as many prawns as I have dispatched in my life, I have never before killed a living being with my teeth. And the prawn knew what I was going to do, and he did not like it.
它在看着我，实际上是把我当成了捕食者，那个要吃掉它的生物。那是一个非常诡异的时刻。尽管我吃的东西很多，在食物链上的位置也不高，我这辈子处理过无数对虾，但我从来没有亲自用牙齿杀死过一个活物。而那只虾知道我要做什么，它不喜欢这样。
And I wasn't quite sure what to do. But if I put it down, the prawn would have died anyway. It's not going to live without its shell, and somebody else would have eaten it, blah-blah-blah. So I bit into it. I bit its body off with my teeth. And the prawn just relaxed in this way that was really eerie.
我不知道该怎么办。但如果我放下它，它反正也会死。没有了壳它活不下去，别人也会吃掉它，诸如此类。所以我咬下去了。我用牙齿咬断了它的身体。那只虾放松了下来，那种感觉真的很诡异。
And the taste of the prawn, the taste of the meat of it was extraordinary. I mean, it was sweet. It was like there was life coursing through it. It was the most alive thing I've ever eaten, obviously literally. But again, it was freaky. It was getting too close to the actual nature of consumption, which is killing a living creature with your teeth.
对虾的味道，它的肉味非常特别。我是说，它是甜的。就像生命在其中流淌。显然，从字面上讲，这是我吃过的最有活力的东西。但再一次，这很怪异。它太接近消费的本质了，那就是用牙齿杀死一个活的生物。
When you bit into the prawn, did you actually bite off its head, its living head, and have its head and its eyes in your mouth?
当你咬下那只虾时，你真的咬断了它的头，那颗活着的头，并且把它的头和眼睛含在嘴里了吗？
No, I bit off its body. And I held the head in my hands.
不，我咬断了它的身体。我把头握在手里。
So you held the head in one hand and the tail in the other and you bit the center?
所以你一只手拿着头，另一只手拿着尾巴，咬了中间？
Right. And I thought that I'd killed it. But in fact, when I put it down, it still had so much life in it that it grabbed a piece of salmon sashimi and wouldn't let go of it. And I don't think I ever want to do that again.
对。我以为我已经杀死了它。但事实上，当我把它放下时，它依然充满活力，它抓住了一块三文鱼刺身，怎么也不肯放手。我想我再也不想做那种事了。
Did you feel like there was something about the experience that made it more-- this word is a little cornier than I intend, but it's the only word that I can think of-- that made it more sacred? That took it out of the mundaneness of the way that we eat, which for most of us is eating without actually tasting and experiencing, and thinking about what we're eating and what on the earth it is that we're killing to survive? Do you think in some way that it's more acceptable to eat an animal if you are more awake to the fact that it is an animal and what's happened to it? Or do you think it really doesn't matter?
你是否觉得这种体验让它变得更加——这个词可能比我本意更俗气，但这是我能想到的唯一词——更加神圣了？这让它摆脱了我们日常进食的平庸，对于大多数人来说，进食往往不经品味，不经历，也不去思考我们吃的是什么，为了生存我们杀死了地球上的什么？你认为如果一个人更清醒地意识到它是一种动物，以及它经历了什么，吃这种动物是否在某种程度上更容易被接受？还是你认为这根本不重要？
I think it matters a great deal. I mean, one of the greatest metaphors in Western civilization is that of Christ, who gave his life so that others might live. And I don't want to be sacrilegious, and I don't want to belittle that myth in any way, but a pig is giving its life so that we might eat. A chicken is giving its life so that we might eat.
我认为这非常重要。西方文明中最伟大的隐喻之一就是基督，他献出生命让别人活着。我不想亵渎神明，也不想贬低那个神话，但猪献出生命让我们吃。鸡献出生命让我们吃。
And I think the least that we can do is to think about that chicken, to think about that calf that we're eating. Not necessarily to be sad for it, but to celebrate it, to be aware of the being that it was, that it wasn't just this bit of bio-engineered protein that somehow managed to find its way onto our plates.
我认为我们至少能做的，是去思考那只鸡，思考我们要吃的这头小牛。不一定要为它感到悲伤，而是要赞美它，要意识到它曾经是一个生命，而不是仅仅是某种不知怎么就出现在我们盘子里的生物工程蛋白质。
Jonathan Gold writes his food column Counter Intelligence for the LA Weekly.
乔纳森·戈尔德为《洛杉矶周刊》撰写美食专栏《反情报》。
Act Two, Last Meal. Consider please, poultry consumers, the role of poultry in Francois Mitterrand's last meal. Mitterrand, you'll recall, was President of France who died at the beginning of 1996. A contradictory and enigmatic man. The French press used to call him the Sphinx. He once actually staged his own assassination to help himself in the polls. Obsessed with history and his place in it.
第二幕，最后的晚餐。请考虑一下，禽类消费者们，禽肉在弗朗索瓦·密特朗最后一餐中的作用。密特朗，你可能记得，是死于1996年初的法国总统。一个矛盾而神秘的人。法国媒体过去常称他为“斯芬克斯”。他实际上曾为了在民意调查中获益而策划了自己的暗杀事件。他痴迷于历史，以及他在历史中的地位。
Michael Paterniti wrote about Mitterrand's last meal for the magazine Esquire. Mitterrand found out that he was dying of cancer. Our story begins just weeks before his death.
迈克尔·帕特尼蒂为《时尚先生》杂志撰写了关于密特朗最后一餐的文章。密特朗发现自己患上了癌症。我们的故事从他去世前几周开始。
Right before Christmas, Mitterrand went to Egypt to commune with the pharaohs. Even though he was extremely ill, he decided that he had to go there one last time.
就在圣诞节前，密特朗去了埃及，与法老们交流。尽管病得很重，他还是决定必须最后去一次那里。
You said he went to Egypt to commune with the pharaohs?
你说他去埃及是为了与法老交流？
Yeah.
是的。
Like, literally with the pharaohs?
就像，真的是与法老本人交流？
Well, he felt this spiritual connection to these leaders of the past. And he studied the lives, and in particular how many of these people died, what their last gestures were. And he felt that his last gesture would have to be equally fitting.
嗯，他感受到了与这些过去领袖的精神联系。他研究了他们的生活，特别是他们中的许多人是如何死去的，他们最后的姿态是什么。他觉得他最后的姿态也必须同样恰当。
Equally grand?
同样宏大？
Yeah. And while he was there, he decided that he was going to have this amazing last meal. What he did was call back to France and made sure that they had this menu that he decided would be it, which was this amazing feast of oyster and foie gras and capon, and finally this little songbird called ortolan, which symbolizes the French soul. And it was this completely forbidden thing to eat ortolan. It's illegal in France to do so.
是的。当他在那里时，他决定要享受一顿丰盛的“最后晚餐”。他回拨电话回法国，确保他们准备了那份他决定的菜单，那是一场由牡蛎、鹅肝酱、阉鸡组成的豪华盛宴，最后还有一种被称为“圃鹀”的小鸣禽，它象征着法国灵魂。而吃圃鹀是完全被禁止的。在法国这样做是违法的。
Because it's an endangered species, right?
因为它是一种濒危物种，对吧？
Yeah. And people who have served ortolan-- chefs have served it in France-- have been fined. And I think in one case, a chef was imprisoned for serving it.
是的。而且那些供应过圃鹀的人——在法国提供过它的厨师——都被罚款了。我想有一次，一位厨师因为供应它而入狱。
Did you look at all into why the ortolan would come to represent the soul of France?
你有没有研究过为什么圃鹀会成为法国灵魂的象征？
It was the food of kings in France. And once it was caught in these tiny traps, in very old times, they would actually poke the eyes of the bird out so the bird would live in complete darkness and just eat 24 hours a day. And then when it was fattened, they would drown it in a kind of cognac. And there was this ritual associated with the preparation of the bird, as well as with eating the bird. Actually in Proust and Fielding, ortolan appear. And they symbolize seduction and adultery and virginity.
那是法国国王的食物。在很久以前，当它们被这些小陷阱抓住时，他们实际上会把鸟的眼睛戳瞎，这样鸟就会生活在完全的黑暗中，一天24小时只吃东西。等它长肥了，他们会把它淹死在某种干邑白兰地里。而且关于这种鸟的烹饪以及吃法，都有某种仪式。实际上在普鲁斯特和菲尔丁的作品中，都有圃鹀出现。它们象征着诱惑、通奸和贞洁。
And one of the things about ortolan is that people eat it with a napkin over their head?
关于圃鹀的一件事是人们吃的时候会用餐巾盖住头？
Right. People put a large cloth napkin over their head. And apparently what the napkin does is it keeps the aroma inside this tent in which you're eating. And the French say that it also keeps God from seeing you eating the little birdie.
是的。人们会把一条大布餐巾盖在头上。显然，餐巾的作用是把香气留在你进食的那个帐篷里。法国人说，这也让上帝看不见你在吃这只小鸟。
Meaning what?
这意味着什么？
Meaning that it's sinful, that the bird is so innocent--
意味着这是罪恶的，因为这只鸟太纯洁了——
And the pleasure so great?
而且那种快乐太巨大了？
--and the pleasure so great that it's a sin.
——而且快乐太巨大了，所以这是一种罪。
And Mitterrand, when he had his last meal, he knew he was dying. And he continued to survive for quite a while after the last meal, right?
而密特朗，当他享用最后晚餐时，他知道自己快死了。他在那顿晚餐后又活了一段时间，对吧？
He lived eight days. And he didn't eat or drink during those days.
他多活了八天。在那几天里，他没有吃任何东西或喝水。
He had just decided he wanted the last food that he had eaten to be the ortolan?
他只是决定了他想吃的最后一种食物是圃鹀？
Yeah. That was what was most incredible to me, is that he had this huge dinner, and then consciously decided that that would be his last meal and then just readied himself for death.
是的。对我来说，最不可思议的是，他吃了一顿大餐，然后有意识地决定那将是他最后一顿饭，然后就为死亡做好了准备。
So you arranged to go to France to try to taste this bird and have this meal, in fact, to try to recreate Mitterrand's last meal?
所以你安排去法国试图品尝这种鸟并享用那顿餐，实际上是为了重现密特朗的最后晚餐？
Right. And it started with 100 phone calls, just to try to locate somebody who would even entertain the notion. And after literally months, there was one chef in Bordeaux who said that he would cook the meal.
是的。一切始于100个电话，只是为了找到一个愿意考虑这个想法的人。在经历了几个月后，波尔多的一位厨师说他愿意烹饪这顿饭。
And so you have this massive meal ending with the bird?
所以你吃了一顿以这种鸟结束的丰盛晚餐？
Yes.
是的。
And what do we know about when Mitterrand ate the bird?
我们知道密特朗是什么时候吃那只鸟的吗？
Well, we know that during the meal, he slipped in and out of consciousness in between the courses. And he would eat ravenously. And then he would just sort of pass out. And he sat at a table separate from the table where all his guests were seated. There were about 30 people there, extended family and friends. And Mitterrand would rise up with each new course and eat. But he really wasn't talking to many people. And he was really focused on trying to finish the meal and taste, apparently, every note in that meal.
嗯，我们知道在用餐期间，他在每道菜之间陷入了昏迷。他会狼吞虎咽地吃，然后就会昏过去。他坐在离所有客人都不同的桌子上。大约有30人在那里，包括远亲和朋友。密特朗随着每道新菜上桌而起身吃。但他真的没和几个人说话。他真的专注于完成那顿饭，显然，品尝了那顿饭的每一个音符。
When you had your meal, do you feel like you were able to achieve that level of awareness where you were tasting every note of the meal? It seems like such a high standard to aspire to.
当你吃那顿饭时，你觉得你达到了那种专注的水平吗？你能品尝出那顿饭的每一个音符吗？这似乎是一个需要仰望的高标准。
I felt like it was the most incredible meal I've eaten. And it was because I was very focused on everything that went into my mouth. And also, because when it came to the ortolan, there's no easy way to eat ortolan. You are forced to taste every bite. And it goes from being completely sublime to being excruciating.
我觉得那是我吃过最不可思议的一顿饭。这是因为我非常专注于进入我嘴里的每一件事。而且，当涉及到圃鹀时，没有简单的方法吃它。你被迫品尝每一口。它从完全的超然变成了令人痛苦。
Describe what it's like to eat the bird. We should say that the bird-- you describe it as the size of your thumb, smaller than your thumb.
描述一下吃这种鸟是什么感觉。我们应该说，这只鸟——你描述它只有你的拇指大小，比你的拇指还小。
Yeah. Yeah, it is. It's about the size of your thumb. And it sits in a-- they serve it in a white cassoulet. And you put the napkin over your head and you duck down toward the cassoulet. And so you are in this space that is completely white-- the white napkin, the white plate, the white cassoulet. And then you have the bird on its back that you lift up and put into your mouth. You cool it by breathing in and out.
是的。没错。它大约有你的拇指那么大。它们把它放在一个白色的卡酥来砂锅里。你把餐巾盖在头上，缩向砂锅。你处于一个完全白色的空间——白色的餐巾，白色的盘子，白色的砂锅。然后你把背朝上的鸟拿起来放进嘴里。你通过吸气和呼气来冷却它。
And this is the entire bird, every part of it?
这是整只鸟吗，身体的每一部分？
Yes. In our case, the chef insisted that we bite off the head and leave the head on the plate. I think in Mitterrand's case, he ate the head too.
是的。在我们这个例子中，厨师坚持我们要咬掉头，把头留在盘子里。我想在密特朗的例子中，他连头也吃了。
OK. So you bite off the head, you leave the head on the plate.
好的。所以你咬掉头，把头留在盘子里。
And then you cool it, and then you begin to chew. And that first bite is incredibly difficult to describe, because it's terrifying. I mean, I was terrified. I was nauseous with the idea of it. But the first bite of the bird changed that. It was incredibly, and almost immediately, delicious. And all these juices were flowing out of it into your mouth, and sort of mingling and co-mingling with everything that was already in your mouth. And it's like this very finely evolved consomme.
然后你冷却它，然后开始咀嚼。第一口很难描述，因为它太可怕了。我是说，我很恐惧。我因为这个想法感到恶心。但鸟的第一口改变了这一切。它令人难以置信，而且几乎立即变得美味。所有的汁液从里面流进你的嘴里，与你嘴里已有的所有东西混合在一起。它就像是一种非常精致的浓汤。
And then you begin to taste the meat. And they're little tender bits of meat. And then I think you begin to taste the organs. And it becomes more bitter. So the sweetness and the tenderness turns bitter.
然后你开始品尝肉。那是少许嫩肉。然后我想你开始品尝器官。它变得更苦了。所以甜味和嫩味变成了苦味。
And then?
然后呢？
And then, well, you keep chewing ortolan until you have chewed it completely. And then you're supposed to swallow it all at once. And there's no other way, really, to consume it. And as you continue to chew, it gets harder and harder, because you're working the bones finally. So the meat and the juices fade, and you suddenly are chewing these bones. And that is when you really, I think, fall into a bit of an existential crisis. Like, what the hell am I doing? And then also, I really think I'm going to throw up.
然后，嗯，你继续咀嚼圃鹀，直到你完全嚼碎它。然后你应该一次全部吞下去。真的没有其他方式可以食用它。随着你继续咀嚼，它变得越来越难，因为你终于要处理骨头了。肉和汁液消失了，你突然在咀嚼这些骨头。我想，那才是你真正陷入某种存在主义危机的时刻。就像，我到底在做什么？然后我也真的觉得我要呕吐了。
And how am I going to swallow these bones?
我该怎么吞下这些骨头？
And how am I going to swallow them? I mean, many people who have never had ortolan before end up spitting it out on the plate. And in fact, at Mitterrand's last meal, a number of the people in the room did spit out their ortolan.
我该怎么吞下它们？我是说，许多以前从未吃过圃鹀的人最终把它吐在了盘子里。事实上，在密特朗的最后一餐中，房间里确实有好几个人把他们的圃鹀吐了出来。
That seems like incredibly bad form, though. You're spitting out the soul of France.
但这看起来礼仪非常糟糕，不是吗？你吐掉了法国的灵魂。
Yeah, you're incredibly gauche if you pull that stunt.
是的，如果你搞那一套，你会显得非常笨拙。
Writer Mike Paterniti. He says after focusing so intensely on eating that one meal, where, like Mitterrand, he tried to taste every flavor, it felt weird to get back to normal eating. It felt a little dirty not to pay attention.
作家迈克·帕特尼蒂。他说，在如此专注于享用那顿饭，像密特朗一样努力品尝每一个味道之后，回到正常的饮食生活感觉很奇怪。如果不留心，感觉有点脏。
Because it takes a lot of energy and concentration when you really taste a meal. It takes concentration and silence.
因为当你真正品尝一顿饭时，它需要大量的能量和专注。它需要专注和沉默。
The way you describe it, it's almost like you're saying that if we were really awake to what the world is giving us in a given meal, it would be hard to eat the meal every single time.
按照你的描述，你几乎是在说，如果我们真的清醒地意识到世界在特定的某一餐中给予我们什么，每次要吃完那顿饭都会很困难。
Yeah, I feel like we would age really quickly.
是的，我觉得我们会老得很快。
But you're saying that we have to deaden ourselves in order to live.
但你是在说，为了活着，我们必须麻痹自己。
I think we do. I don't think we make enough time to eat. And if we haven't made enough time to eat, then it's better not to taste what we are eating. It's easier.
我想我们确实如此。我不认为我们有足够的时间去吃饭。如果我们没有足够的时间去吃饭，那么最好还是不要品尝我们在吃什么。这样更容易。
Coming up, tiny Styrofoam balls singing in Italian. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，微小的泡沫塑料球用意大利语唱歌。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, during this time between Thanksgiving and Christmas, a time of year when poultry consumption in this country is at its greatest, we bring you our Poultry Slam, stories of chickens, turkeys, ducks, fowl of all kind, and our relationship with them. We have come to act three of our program. Act Three, Chicken Diva. Chickens are what we make of them so much of the time. And if you need any proof of that, we have this story from Jack Hitt.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天，在感恩节和圣诞节之间的这段时期，这个国家家禽消费量最大的时候，我们为您带来我们的“禽类大放送”，讲述鸡、火鸡、鸭子、各种鸟类，以及我们与它们的关系。我们已经来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，鸡肉天后。很多时候，鸡就是我们所创造的样子。如果你需要任何证明，我们有这个来自杰克·希特的故事。
Oddly enough, it wasn't Susan who was obsessed with chickens. It was Kenny, a pal who worked backstage at the 92nd Street Y in New York. His house was filled with chicken cups, chicken masks, porcelain chickens. He got the whole staff onto chickens, including Susan. For a time there in the '80s, poultry related jokes and references became the fast way to get a laugh at the Y. I guess most of us are condemned to see nothing more than the easy comedy of chickens.
奇怪的是，痴迷于鸡的并不是苏珊。是肯尼，一个在纽约第92街Y中心后台工作的朋友。他的房子里到处是鸡杯子、鸡面具、瓷鸡。他让整个员工都迷上了鸡，包括苏珊。在80年代的那段时间里，禽类相关的笑话和引用成了在Y中心博取欢笑的捷径。我想我们大多数人注定只能看到鸡身上容易理解的喜剧成分。
But Susan Vitucci saw something else, their potential greatness, their hidden beauty, their grandeur. One day, she glued together some finger puppets for a 10-minute rendition of the Chicken Little story for her nephew. That was 14 years ago. Today, it is a full-length opera, enjoyed by a cult following whenever it goes up in a workshop or a cafe or a small theater. It's still performed with finger puppets, but now it has a complete score written by a noted composer, Henry Krieger, who did Dreamgirls. The Chicken Little opera he wrote with Susan Vitucci is called Love's Fowl. Needless to say, that's F-O-W-L.
但苏珊·维图奇看到了别的东西，它们的潜在伟大、隐藏的美、它们的庄严。有一天，她把一些手指玩偶粘在一起，为她的侄子演绎了10分钟的《小鸡快跑》故事。那是14年前的事了。今天，它是一部完整的歌剧，无论是在工作坊、咖啡馆还是小剧院上演，都会受到狂热追捧。它仍然是用手指玩偶表演的，但现在有了由著名作曲家亨利·克里格（他创作了《追梦女郎》）编写的完整乐谱。他和苏珊·维图奇创作的《小鸡快跑》歌剧被称为《爱的家禽》。不用说，那是F-O-W-L，家禽。
Well, we were going to start with the opening-- "Siamo del teatro repetorio delle mollette," "we are the clothespin repertory theatre"-- and we have a special singing guest for you, which I don't know--
好吧，我们要从开头开始——“Siamo del teatro repetorio delle mollette”，“我们是衣夹剧目剧院”——而且我们为您准备了一位特别的歌唱嘉宾，我不知道——
Susan and I are sitting at Henry's baby grand piano. Henry's guest is his Maltese terrier named Toby.
苏珊和我坐在亨利的三角钢琴旁。亨利的嘉宾是他那只名叫托比的马耳他梗犬。
Perhaps Toby would be kind enough to join me up here--
也许托比愿意陪我一起上来——
Yeah, would he sit on your lap for this?
是的，他会坐在你腿上做这件事吗？
--at the piano. Yeah, let's see what we can do.
——在钢琴旁。是的，让我们看看我们能做什么。
[PIANO PLAYING]
[钢琴演奏]
OK, listen carefully. Because once Toby gets going, he actually harmonizes with Henry and Susan.
好的，仔细听。因为一旦托比开始表演，他实际上会和亨利和苏珊合唱。
[MUSIC - "SIAMO DEL TEATRO REPETORIO DELLE MOLLETTE"]
[音乐 - "SIAMO DEL TEATRO REPETORIO DELLE MOLLETTE"]
You may have noticed that this libretto is in Italian, just like a real opera.
你可能已经注意到这个剧本是意大利语的，就像真正的歌剧一样。
Before it was just a bunch of puppets in a box with a good idea. And then suddenly, as soon as it went into Italian, it became something bigger than what it had been. And it's because when it's in English, we all know it, and it's really not that interesting. It's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. As soon as it's in Italian, it gives us enough distance that we can come in. It's like the lover who doesn't want you-- you don't want anybody more than you want the one who doesn't want you. Right? And so then it's sort of the same thing.
在它之前，这只是一堆放在盒子里、有着好想法的玩偶。然后突然间，一旦它变成意大利语，它就变得比以前更宏大了。这是因为当它是英语时，我们大家都懂，它真的没那么有趣。就像，是的，是的，是的。一旦它是意大利语，它就给了我们足够的距离，让我们能够进入。就像那个不想理你的爱人——你最想要的永远是那个不想理你的人。对吧？所以这是一样的道理。
You may recall that when you last heard of Little, back in kindergarten, she was just an average barn-door fowl who had an acorn drop on her head, which she mistakenly understood to be the sky falling. Her alarms excited her friends, Goosey Loosey, Turkey Lurkey, and Ducky Lucky. And they join her for a journey to the king to tell him the important news.
你可能记得当你最后一次在幼儿园听说小鸡时，她只是一只普通的谷仓门前的小鸟，头上掉下了一颗橡子，她错误地理解为天塌下来了。她的警报惊动了她的朋友们——鹅、火鸡和鸭子。他们陪她一起去见国王，告诉他这个重要的消息。
On the way, they meet up with Sly Fox, Little's pals eagerly accept his invitation for dinner. Literally, as it turns out. Fortunately for Little, hunger is not enough to distract her from her mission and she treks on. When she meets the King, he tells her that the sky is not falling. It's just an acorn. So the enlightened Chicken Little returns to her coop. And that's where the story ends.
在路上，他们遇到了狡猾的狐狸，小鸡的朋友们急切地接受了他的晚餐邀请。事实证明，字面意思就是晚餐。幸运的是，饥饿不足以让她分心而偏离任务，她继续跋涉。当她见到国王时，他告诉她天没有塌。那只是一颗橡子。于是觉醒的小鸡回到了鸡舍。故事就在那里结束了。
Like Goldilocks and so many children's fables, the actual meaning of the story is obscure. What are we to take away from Little's experience? I like to think it's that Little is rewarded with life, precisely because she went off on this quixotic mission, totally in the grip of a wrong idea. By clinging to that belief, however crazy, she managed to free herself from the ugly, Darwinian world of the barnyard and of its mandate, eat or be eaten.
像《金发姑娘》和许多儿童寓言一样，这个故事的实际意义很晦涩。我们要从这一经历中得到什么？我喜欢认为，小鸡之所以被奖励生命，正是因为她进行了这次唐吉诃德式的任务，完全被一个错误的想法所俘虏。通过坚持那个信念，无论多么疯狂，她成功地把自己从谷仓院子里那个丑陋、达尔文式的“不吃就被吃”的法则中解放了出来。
The children's fable barely figures into the story. It's just one small episode in the life of Chicken Little, now known as La Pulcina Piccola. After the acorn incident, she goes on to become an internationally renowned figure in almost every field imaginable, a diva of politics, academe, theatre, art, derring-do. Like Venus, she arrives from some other world, transported on a scallop shell.
儿童寓言几乎没出现在故事里。这只是小鸡生活中的一个小插曲，她现在被称为“小拉皮奇科拉”。橡子事件后，她继续成为几乎所有领域都闻名遐迩的人物，政治、学术、戏剧、艺术、冒险的歌剧天后。就像维纳斯一样，她来自另一个世界，坐在一只扇贝壳上被运送而来。
But the triumphs of her life begin after a youthful love affair with a fighting cock ends bitterly. And she consoles herself, as we all do at some point in our lives, by plunging into Shakespeare. She becomes an overnight sensation as an actress, celebrated all over the world for one role. Juliet? Cleopatra? Ophelia?
但她生命中的胜利开始于与一只斗鸡的青春恋情苦涩地结束后。她安慰自己，就像我们生命中某个时刻都会做的那样，沉浸在莎士比亚的作品中。她一夜之间成为了轰动一时的女演员，因一个角色而享誉全球。朱丽叶？埃及艳后？奥菲莉亚？
The company then performs an excerpt, a recreation of her signature role, which is Richard III. Well, you know, Sarah Bernhardt did Hamlet.
剧团随后表演了一个片段，重现了她的招牌角色，也就是《理查三世》。好吧，你知道，萨拉·伯恩哈特曾演过哈姆雷特。
Well, there's a great tradition of women playing the men's roles in Shakespeare. But I think Richard III is one of the more rare roles to be played by a woman.
好吧，女性扮演莎士比亚男性角色有很长的传统。但我认为《理查三世》是女性扮演的比较罕见的角色之一。
Well, that's how adventuresome an actress this chicken was.
好吧，这就是那只鸡作为一个女演员的冒险精神。
I can assure you, there's nothing like watching a four-inch tall finger puppet crying out "a horse, a horse, my kingdom for a horse," in Italian. Not to mention that that puppet is a chicken surrounded by a whole supporting cast of poultry and other avian supernumeraries. Susan says that artistically, there's something special about chickens.
我可以保证，没有什么比看着一个4英寸高的手指玩偶在用意大利语喊出“一匹马，一匹马，用我的王国换一匹马”更神奇的了。更不用说那个玩偶是一只鸡，周围还有一整套禽类和其他鸟类群众演员。苏珊说，艺术上，鸡有什么特别之处。
They're a clean slate, in a way. You can put anything on them. You can project anything onto them. Because it's not like they have-- to me, at least-- a very strong personality.
它们是一张白纸。你可以在它们身上放任何东西。你可以把任何东西投射到它们身上。因为在我看来，它们不像是有很强的个性。
Except for La Pulcina. In the opera, she moves into the field of archaeology-- masters it, needless to say-- and makes a great discovery, the last tomb of Gallapatra. But not before she sails the seven seas, is shipwrecked, gets rescued, but it's by pirates, and then she meets the pirate king.
除了“小拉”之外。在歌剧中，她进入了考古领域——不用说，精通了它——并做出了重大发现，加拉帕特拉的最后陵墓。但在此之前，她航行在七大洋，遭遇海难，获救，但是被海盗救的，然后她遇到了海盗王。
As soon as he meets her, he falls in love with her, because of her sweet spirit. Because she comes in, and she says, here you see a little chicken who, although I'm dripping wet, I'm proud and yellow.
一见到她，他就爱上了她，因为她甜美的精神。因为她走过来，她说，在这里你看到了一只小鸡，虽然我全身湿透，但我骄傲而金黄。
Let me repeat that lyric for you in a pure translation. "Although I stand before you, a chicken, who is dripping wet, I am proud, and I am yellow." OK, back to Susan.
让我用纯翻译为你重复那句歌词。“虽然我站在你面前，一只全身湿透的小鸡，但我很骄傲，而且我是金黄色的。”好了，回到苏珊身上。
And although I've loved and I have lost, I have learned to follow the call of adventure. So let's sail on.
尽管我爱过，也失去过，但我已经学会了追随冒险的呼唤。所以让我们继续航行。
Keep in mind that all of the action-- like everything that occurs in every Susan Vitucci production, ever since the first one for her nephew and continuing to this day-- occurs among characters created by sticking a small painted Styrofoam ball onto a larger painted Styrofoam ball, poking in two map tacks for eyes, gluing on a tiny felt beak, and then impaling the whole thing on top of one of those really old-fashioned clothespins that a '40s cartoon figure would clamp to his nose around a chunk of Limburger cheese.
请记住，所有的动作——就像每部苏珊·维图奇作品中发生的每一件事一样，自从为她侄子创作的第一部以来直到今天——都是在一些角色之间发生的：这些角色是把一个小涂漆的泡沫塑料球粘在一个较大的涂漆泡沫塑料球上，插上两个图钉做眼睛，粘上一个小毡嘴，然后把整个东西插在那些老式的衣夹顶上，就像40年代的卡通人物会在林堡奶酪块上夹在鼻子上一样。
And I could go on. She takes a cowboy lover on the American frontier while on a lecture tour. Then there's an affair with an Italian professor, modeled on a real 15th century naturalist who wrote a treatise on chickens. There's always another adventure, even outside the opera. Susan has written-- or as she puts it, translated-- La Pulcina Piccola's diaries, which detail the other adventures that happen in between those in the opera. There are 60 pages so far, excerpts of which have appeared in Clotheslines, the official fan club newsletter of the opera. It's masthead lists every category of donor.
我还可以继续列举。她在巡回讲学时在美国边境有一个牛仔情人。还有一个与意大利教授的恋情，灵感来自一位写过鸡的论著的现实中15世纪自然学家。总有另一场冒险，即使在歌剧之外。苏珊写了——或者如她所说，翻译了——“小拉”的日记，详细记录了歌剧之间发生的其他冒险。目前已经有60页了，其中节选出现在《衣绳》上，这是歌剧的官方粉丝俱乐部通讯。它的刊头列出了每一类捐赠者。
Zealot, fanatic, worshiper, admirer. A zealot has to give $250, a fanatic $100. Do you have any zealots?
狂热者、崇拜者、敬慕者、仰慕者。狂热者必须捐赠250美元，崇拜者100美元。你有什么狂热者吗？
Oh yeah. In fact, actually, you can just give however much you want and call yourself whatever you want, so that we have people called-- what is it-- belli amici pennuti, which means fine feathered friends. We have a couple of those. And we have lovers. We have a couple of lovers.
哦，是的。事实上，你可以随便给多少钱，然后自称任何你想称呼的东西，所以我们有被称为——什么来着——“belli amici pennuti”，意思是“美好的羽毛朋友”。我们有几个这样的。我们还有恋人。我们有几对恋人。
I'm not joking when I tell you that the high-end donation is $500. People take this campy finger-puppet opera quite seriously. When I was talking to Henry Krieger, he recalled the night he first saw a bare-bones production of it at the West Bank Cafe in New York. And it was Krieger who approached Vitucci, begging to write music for it. Love's Fowl has this strange effect on people.
我没有开玩笑，高端捐赠是500美元。人们相当认真地对待这个营地风格的手指玩偶歌剧。当我和亨利·克里格交谈时，他回忆起第一次在纽约西岸咖啡馆观看该剧简陋版的那天晚上。正是克里格找到维图奇，恳求为它创作音乐。《爱的家禽》对人们有这种奇怪的影响。
I didn't understand it until Susan loaned me a videotape of one performance. To be honest, I thought I would be annoyed at the intentional irony and hokiness of the puppets. But there I was with my three-year-old daughter, who loved the show, watching a plastic bird pantomime one of the simplest human moments, but also one of the most profound-- the confession of a great love, in this case, with a Cock Robin.
我直到苏珊借给我一份演出的录像带才理解它。老实说，我原以为我会对这些玩偶故意制造的讽刺和陈词滥调感到恼火。但我和我三岁的女儿在那里，她很喜欢这个节目，看着一只塑料鸟模仿人类最简单但也最深刻的时刻之一——一场伟大的爱情的告白，在这种情况下，是一只知更鸟。
The song that she sings as she enters goes, "I am a chicken and ready for love. My heart is as fragile as the egg from which I was born. Treat me gently, and so will I treat you. Together from earthly love, we will reach for the divine." And then she sings, "I'm a chicken and I can't fly without love. My heart is as strong as the egg from which I was born." And so forth. And so it is only with Cock Robin that she flies.
她入场时唱的歌是，“我是一只鸡，准备好去爱了。我的心像我出生的蛋一样脆弱。温柔地对待我，我也会如此对待你。从世俗的爱情一起，我们将触及神圣。”然后她唱道，“我是一只鸡，没有爱我无法飞行。我的心像我出生的蛋一样坚强。”等等。所以只有和知更鸟在一起，她才能飞翔。
And after they've agreed to fly together and they are soaring in the air, Cock Robin is shot and killed, murdered by a jealous sparrow. I couldn't believe it, but I was getting choked up, especially when Cock Robin appeared on the stage, his Styrofoam body spray-painted black for the lament, his little magic marker eyes drawn as X's. I gathered my daughter in my arms and held on tight, as I was helplessly drawn into an expression of the grief and suffering of this little sad bird.
在他们同意一起飞翔并翱翔在空中后，知更鸟被枪杀身亡，被一只嫉妒的麻雀谋杀。我简直不敢相信，但我哽咽了，特别是当知更鸟出现在舞台上时，他泡沫塑料的身体喷上了黑色，为了哀悼，他画在上面的小记号笔眼睛画成了X。我把女儿揽在怀里紧紧抱着，因为我无助地被卷入了这只悲伤小鸟的悲伤和痛苦的表达中。
In this era of slick special effects, there was something unexpectedly liberating in the marriage of this crude medium-- painted Styrofoam balls bobbing up and down behind a cardboard box-- and the high, melodramatic art of Italian opera. Picture it.
在这个精美特效的时代，这种粗糙媒介的结合——在纸板箱后面上下跳动的涂漆泡沫塑料球——和意大利歌剧高亢的戏剧艺术结合中，有一种意想不到的解放感。想象一下。
I want a subscription to that newsletter.
我想要一份那个通讯的订阅。
Are you going to do this? I mean, are you going to be working with Pulcina Piccola, you think, for the rest of your life?
你要做这个吗？我是说，你认为你会和“小拉”一起工作余生吗？
It's possible. And I like working with her because I get to go into a world that's inhabited by a very sweet spirit. And because it's very small. I could never have afforded to produce this show with people. But I could afford to do it with clothespins.
有可能。我喜欢和她一起工作，因为我可以进入一个被非常甜美的精神占据的世界。而且因为它是非常小的。我永远负担不起用真人来制作这个节目。但我负担得起用衣夹来做。
So I can do as big a production as I want with clothespins. I can have stuff fly in and out and come in from traps. And I can have all kinds of fancy, flashy stuff that costs millions of dollars to do on Broadway. And it would cost me $200, because I had to buy lots and lots and lots of Styrofoam and clothespins and stuff, and all this, and a new table maybe. And I get to do whatever I want.
所以我可以用衣夹做任何我想要的大型制作。我可以让东西飞进飞出，从陷阱里进来。我可以拥有各种昂贵、闪亮的东西，在百老汇做需要花费数百万美元。而它只会花我200美元，因为我不得不买很多很多的泡沫塑料和衣夹之类的东西，还有所有这些，也许还有一张新桌子。而且我可以做任何我想做的事。
Jack Hitt lives in New Haven. The online home of the opera is pulcina.org.
杰克·希特住在纽黑文。歌剧的在线主页是pulcina.org。
Act Four, The Meaning of a Chicken. We close our show today with this story from David Rakoff, which begins far from any chicken house.
第四幕，鸡的意义。我们今天以大卫·拉科夫的这个故事结束我们的节目，这个故事开始于远离任何养鸡场的地方。
Friday nights of my childhood and early adolescence were spent at weekly meetings of a Socialist, Zionist youth movement. My brother, sister, and I were members. The meetings took a variety of forms. There were the earnest discussions of Marx and the great Labor Zionist thinkers like Theodore Herzl and A. D. Gordon, bull sessions about who in the group had hurt whose feelings, and playing air guitar to "Come Sail Away" by Styx. All activities that formed us into pretty deeply committed young Socialists, ready at the age of 15 for the ultimate prize the movement could bestow, a summer living and working on a kibbutz, one of the collective farms that were a central part of settling the Jewish state.
我童年和青春期早期的周五晚上是在一个社会主义犹太复国主义青年运动的每周会议上度过的。我和我的兄弟姐妹都是成员。会议形式多种多样。有关于马克思和西奥多·赫茨尔、A.D.戈登等伟大的劳动犹太复国主义思想家的认真讨论，有关于团体中谁伤害了谁感情的谈话，还有随着Styx乐队的《Come Sail Away》弹空气吉他。所有这些活动把我们塑造成了相当坚定的年轻社会主义者，在15岁时就准备好接受运动所能赋予的最终奖项：一个在基布兹生活和工作的夏天，这是构成建立犹太国家的中心部分集体农场之一。
There we would meet other members of the movement from all over the world, and spend many a happy hour engaged in honest labor, laughingly baling sheaves of wheat, picking olives, oranges, peaches, grapes, the sweat on our brows a shining reminder of the nobility of collective farming. In the evenings, we would gather together and dance around the fire, sing Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young songs, and if one's older siblings were any indication, lose our virginity. Years later, we would renounce our bourgeois upbringings and return to Israel, making lives of simple, agrarian bliss.
在那里，我们将见到来自世界各地的运动其他成员，并度过许多快乐的时光，从事诚实的劳动，笑着打捆小麦，采摘橄榄、橙子、桃子、葡萄，额头上的汗水是提醒集体农场高尚性的闪亮标志。晚上，我们会聚在一起围着火堆跳舞，唱Crosby、Stills、Nash和Young的歌，如果有哥哥姐姐在的话，还会失去童贞。多年后，我们将摒弃我们资产阶级的成长背景，回到以色列，过上简单的农耕幸福生活。
This would all change for me in one single evening in a shed of 5,000 chickens. The kibbutz I was assigned to was one of the oldest in Israel, settled in 1928 by Jews from Russia, Poland, and Germany. For the most part, our arrival was met with little to no notice. We were just another group of volunteers, no different from the countless other Europeans and Australians just passing through, taking time out to pick fruit, work on their tans, and contracts cystitis from their rampant and unchecked coitus.
这一切因为5000只鸡的棚子里的一个晚上而对我彻底改变。我被分配到的基布兹是以色列最古老的基布兹之一，由俄罗斯、波兰和德国的犹太人于1928年定居。在大多数情况下，我们的到来几乎无人问津。我们只是另一批志愿者，与无数路过的其他欧洲人和澳大利亚人没什么不同，他们花时间摘水果、晒黑皮肤，并从他们肆无忌惮、不受限制的性交中感染膀胱炎。
But we were different. We were members of the movement. I thought that our political ardor would be immediately apparent. I had visions of our bus being greeted by garlanded, folk-dancing youth, so happy to have us there to share in their dream. I had been raised on a fairly steady diet of just such Socialist Utopian Ziegfeld numbers, songs, film strips, and oral histories that all attested to just this scenario. Trees weren't simply trees. They were jungle gyms of plenty with smiling children clambering over their branches. A field was somewhere you brought your guitar, so that your comrades could dance down the rows after the day's work was over.
但我们不同。我们是运动的成员。我以为我们的政治热情会立刻显现出来。我幻想我们的巴士受到花环装饰的、跳民族舞的年轻人的迎接，他们非常高兴我们能在那里分享他们的梦想。我在这种社会主义乌托邦式的齐格菲尔德歌舞秀、歌曲、幻灯片和口述历史的稳定饮食中长大，这些都证明了这种情况。树木不仅仅是树木。它们是丰收的丛林游乐场，微笑着的孩子在树枝上攀爬。田野是你带着吉他去的地方，这样你的同志们可以在一天的工作结束后在行间跳舞。
I was assigned to pick pears. Work would begin at 4:00 AM and finish sometime mid-morning before the heat had set in. How filled with fervor I was that first morning, the light barely dawning as I headed out in the back of the truck, wearing my simple work shirt, a pair of shorts, and the traditional sun hat worn by so many pioneers who had come before me to make the desert bloom. I should pause here to point out that we actually said things like, "make the desert bloom" all of the time. So off I headed to the orchard.
我被分配去摘梨。工作从凌晨4点开始，在热浪来袭之前的中午时分结束。第一天早上我真是充满了热情，天色微明时，我穿着简单的工装衬衫、短裤和许多先驱者戴的那种让沙漠开花的传统太阳帽，坐在卡车后面出发了。我应该在这里停一下，指出我们实际上一直都在说“让沙漠开花”之类的话。于是我就出发去果园了。
I know I sound like the Central Casting New Yorker I've turned myself into with single-minded determination when I say this. But the main problem with working in the fields is that the sun is just always shining. Dyed-in-the-wool Northerner that I am, it became apparent after about two days that I was completely unsuited to working outside, and I was moved around among the kibbutz's various interior jobs, the furniture factory, the metal irrigation parts factory, and the kitchen, assured all the while by the group leader that there was nothing emasculating or ersatz Socialist in being moved inside. After all, each according to his needs, each according to his abilities. My abilities seemed lie in passing out from heat stroke after a scant two hours in an orchard.
我知道我说这话时听起来像我极力把自己变成的那个“中央选角纽约人”。但田间工作的最大问题是太阳总是在照耀。像我这样根深蒂固的北方人，两天后就很明显我不适合户外工作，我被调动在基布兹各种室内工作之间，家具厂、金属灌溉配件厂和厨房，组长一直向我保证，被调到室内没什么让人感到阉割感或假社会主义的东西。毕竟，各尽所能，按需分配。我的能力似乎在于在果园待了短短两个小时后就因中暑而昏倒。
This continued for weeks. It was a somewhat idyllic, if not a mite monotonous, existence. That is, until the long night of the chickens. The boys of our group were gathered together one day, and told in the hushed tones reserved for trying to avert impending disaster, that we would forgo our regular work details and spend the night from midnight until dawn packing truckloads of poultry.
这种情况持续了数周。这是一种相当田园诗般的生活，即使有一点单调。也就是，直到那个漫长的“鸡之夜”。有一天，我们组的男孩们聚在一起，被以一种为试图避免迫在眉睫的灾难而保留的低沉语调告知，我们将放弃常规工作细节，整晚从午夜到黎明打包卡车满载的禽类。
Why this needed to be done with such urgent secrecy under cover of night, and why the girls were excused, was never explained to us, and we didn't ask. We greeted the news with the respectful Hemingway silence of the Y chromosome. No dopey girls allowed. It was all imbued with nocturnal, testicular melodrama, like some summer stock production of Das Boot.
为什么这需要在深夜秘密进行，为什么女孩们被免除了，没人向我们解释，我们也没问。我们带着那种海明威式的沉默接受了这个消息。没有笨女孩允许。这一切都充满了夜间睾丸式的自恋，就像某种夏季临时演出的《从海底出击》。
We slept that evening from 9:00 to 11:00, what I would come to know later, in a far different context, as a disco nap. We rose, drank some tea. The girls sprayed perfume into some handkerchiefs for us to wear around our noses and mouths. And we were off in trucks to do battle with the insurgent chickens. The scene had everything but the diner waitress standing in the road watching us go, worriedly wiping her hands on her gingham apron.
那天晚上我们从9点睡到11点，也就是我后来在完全不同的背景下所知的“迪斯科午睡”。我们起床，喝了点茶。女孩们在一些手帕上喷了香水给我们戴在鼻子和嘴周围。我们出发去卡车上与叛乱的鸡战斗。现场除了路边站着看着我们离去、担心地用格子围裙擦着手的餐馆服务员外，应有尽有。
The chicken coop of the kibbutz was a one-storied structure of corrugated iron, about half the size of a football field. It emitted a low rumbling, a vague buzz that you could hear from far away. And of course, from even farther away, there was the smell, a smell of such head-kicking intensity as to make a perfume-sprayed handkerchief almost adorable in its valiant naivety, Wile E. Coyote warding off a falling boulder with his paper parasol.
基布兹的鸡舍是一座波纹铁单层结构，大约半个足球场大。它发出一种低沉的隆隆声，一种你从很远就能听到的模糊嗡嗡声。当然，从更远的地方，有一种味道，一种强烈的强度，让喷了香水的手帕在它勇敢的天真中几乎显得可爱，就像威利·E·小狼用纸遮阳伞抵挡落石一样。
Chicken [BLEEP] is horrible stuff, Unlike cow manure, which according to David Foster Wallace smells "warm and herbal and blameless," chicken [BLEEP] is an olfactory insult, a snarling, saw-toothed, ammoniac, cheesy smell, needlessly gratuitously disgusting. A stench of such assaultive tenacity that it burns your eyes. Rather than making you never want to eat a chicken again, it simply makes you angry. It makes you hold a grudge. You'll eat chicken again, by God, and you'll chew really, really hard.
鸡屎是可怕的东西，不像牛粪，根据大卫·福斯特·华莱士的说法，闻起来“温暖、草本且无害”，鸡屎是一种嗅觉侮辱，一种咆哮、锯齿状、氨味、奶酪味，毫无必要、无故的恶心。一种如此具有攻击性的恶臭，它会灼伤你的眼睛。与其让你永远不想再吃鸡，它只会让你生气。它会让你怀恨在心。你会再吃鸡肉的，看在上帝的份上，而且你会嚼得非常、非常用力。
One of the barrel-chested Israelis shows us what to do. Pick up four chickens in each hand. This is done by grabbing hold of the birds by one leg. "If the leg snaps," he says, "it doesn't matter. Just to get four in each hand. B'seder," he says, "OK?" He faces us holding the requisite eight, four in each hand, living masses of writhing feathers. He looks like some German expressionist cheerleader, his pompoms alive, convulsing, filthy. "Who will see their dreams fall away into the abyss and eventually succumb to the crushing sadness and meaningless of it all? We will! And what does that spell? Madness! Louder, I can't hear you!"
一个桶状胸膛的以色列人向我们展示该怎么做。每只手抓四只鸡。这是通过抓住鸟的一条腿来完成的。“如果腿断了，”他说，“没关系。只要每只手抓四只。B'seder，”他说，“好吧？”他对着我们拿着必要的八只，每只手四只，蠕动着的活羽毛团。他看起来像某种德国表现主义拉拉队长，他的绒球在颤动、痉挛、污秽。“谁会看着他们的梦想跌入深渊，最终屈服于那种毁灭性的悲伤和无意义？我们会！这拼出来是什么？疯狂！大声点，我听不见你们！”
He crams the chickens roughly into a blue plastic crate smeared with wet guano. "And you close the lid and chick chack," he tells us, clapping his hands with that's-that finality. Before I even try, I know that I will not be able to do this. It is midnight, and we will be here until dawn, or until the truck is piled to capacity with crated birds. I walk out into the sea of chickens. I reach down and grab one. Its leg a slightly thicker segmented chopstick.
他把鸡粗暴地塞进一个涂满了湿鸟粪的蓝色塑料箱里。“然后你关上盖子， chick chack，”他告诉我们，用那种“就是这样”的结局感拍着手。在我尝试之前，我就知道我做不到。现在是午夜，我们将在这里待到黎明，或者直到卡车堆满箱子里的鸟。我走进鸡的海洋。我伸出手抓了一只。它的腿像一根稍微粗一点的分段筷子。
I recoil and stand up. I take a fetid breath, regroup, and bend down with new resolve, grab the chicken by its body with both hands, thinking somehow that might be preferable. Although how I think I'm going to get eight of them this way, I'm not sure. Its ribs expand and contract under my fingers, a dirty, warm, live umbrella. I drop the bird as if it were boiling hot.
我退缩了，站了起来。我深吸了一口恶臭，重组了一下，带着新的决心弯下腰，用双手抓住鸡的身体，觉得那样可能会更好。虽然我不知道我怎么能用这种方法抓到八只。它的肋骨在我的手指下扩张和收缩，像一把脏兮兮、温暖、活生生的伞。我像丢掉滚烫的东西一样丢掉了那只鸟。
My friends are all grabbing handfuls of poultry and shoving them into crates, unmindful of splayed wings, attempted peckings of their forearms, and the horrible premorbid squawking of birds on their way to slaughter. My sensibilities are not offended by the processing of animals for foods. I don't care about chickens. I fairly define anthropocentric. I'm crazy about the food chain and love being at the top of it. But like the making of sausages, federal legislation, and the heartwarming film work of Robin Williams, there are some things I just don't want to witness.
我的朋友们都在抓着一把把禽类，把它们塞进箱子里，不管翅膀张开、手臂被啄，以及那些在前往屠宰场途中的鸟发出的可怕的临终叫声。我的感官并没有被加工供食物的动物所冒犯。我不在乎鸡。我相当以人为中心。我疯狂地迷恋食物链，喜欢处于顶端。但就像制造香肠、联邦立法和罗宾·威廉姆斯感人的电影作品一样，有些事情我就是不想亲眼目睹。
I leave the coop and go out to the trucks. Hoisting myself up onto the flatbed, I start to help with the stacking of the full crates. I know that my unilateral decision to change my task is met with displeasure on the part of the men who run the coop, but I do not care. [SPEAKING HEBREW] "What's the matter with him," the head of the work detail asks when he sees me on the truck. [SPEAKING HEBREW] He has answered using the female pronoun when referring to me. "The lady doesn't like the chickens."
我离开了鸡舍，走向卡车。爬上平板卡车，我开始帮忙堆放满载的箱子。我知道我改变任务的单方面决定遭到了经营鸡舍的人们的不满，但我不在乎。[希伯来语]“他怎么了，”负责工作的头儿看到我在卡车上时问。[希伯来语]他用阴性代词称呼我。“这个女人不喜欢鸡。”
It would be years before I was referred to as "she" again, and then very rarely and only as a joke by friends. I turn around to look at the men, making it quite clear to them that I understand what they're saying. The man who called me "she" avoids my eyes and busies himself with straightening a pile of crates and tightening the tarpaulin on the side of the truck. "You're right," I tell him in Hebrew. "She doesn't like the chickens."
还要过多年我才会被再次称为“她”，而且那时极少，也只是朋友间开玩笑。我转身看着那些人，很清楚地让他们知道我听懂了他们在说什么。那个称我为“她”的男人避开了我的目光，忙于整理一堆箱子和拉紧卡车侧面的防水布。“你是对的，”我用希伯来语告诉他。“她不喜欢鸡。”
At that very moment, I saw that I would never live on a kibbutz. I would not lose my virginity that summer to any of the girls from the group. Indeed, I would not care to do so. I am grateful to that macho blowhard. He made me consciously realize what I had always known but been somehow unable to say to myself. He's right. I don't like chickens. I like men.
就在那一刻，我看到我永远不会住在基布兹。那个夏天我不会把童贞交给组里的任何女孩。事实上，我也不想这样做。我很感激那个大男子主义的吹牛大王。他让我有意识地意识到我一直知道但一直无法对自己说出的事实。他是对的。我不喜欢鸡。我喜欢男人。
Now I live in Manhattan, the un-kibbutz, where the words Karl and Marx generally bring up associations of Lagerfeld and Groucho. At camp when I was young, I, and the other children of affluent professionals, would gather under the trees every day to sing before going in to lunch. One of the songs was always "The Internationale," the hymn of the proletariat. One summer, we were even told to sing it with our left fists raised. We were, none of us, by any stretch of the imagination, what could be described as prisoners of starvation, wretched of the earth or enthralled slaves. Admittedly, they are all catchier metaphors and easier to scan than arise ye children of psychiatrists. But they had little to nothing to do with us personally.
现在我住在曼哈顿，那个“非基布兹”的地方，那里“卡尔”和“马克思”这两个词通常会引起对拉格斐和马克斯的联想。小时候在夏令营，我和其他富裕家庭的孩子每天午餐前都会聚在树下唱歌。其中一首歌总是《国际歌》，无产阶级的赞歌。有一个夏天，我们甚至被告知要在左拳举起时唱它。我们谁都不是什么忍饥挨饿的囚犯、受苦的地球人或受奴役的奴隶。诚然，它们都是比“起来，精神病学家的孩子们”更朗朗上口、更容易扫描的隐喻。但它们与我们个人几乎没有任何关系。
And yet for those few moments when we were singing, those words seemed so true. How can I describe to you that 11-year-old's sense of purpose? That thrill of belonging to something larger, something outside of my own body? The sheer heart-stopping beauty of a world of justice and perfection rising on new foundations? And that one line, "we have been naught, we shall be all." Naught-- it spoke as much about my wish to be delivered from this pre-adolescent self-loathing as it did to any consciousness of liberating the masses. But it held such promise of what I might hope for that even now, as I write this, I can still call up that old fervor. It still makes my breath catch in my throat.
然而，在我们唱歌的那几分钟里，那些话似乎如此真实。我该如何向你描述那个11岁孩子的目标感？那种属于更宏大东西的快感，某种在我自己身体之外的东西？一个正义和完美的世界在新的基础上建立起来的令人心跳停止的美？还有那句“我们一无所有，我们终将一切”。“无”——它既谈到了我希望从这种青春期前的自我厌恶中解脱出来的愿望，也谈到了对解放大众的任何意识。但它承载着我对可能希望的东西的承诺，以至于即使现在，当我写下这些时，我仍然能唤起那种古老的热情。它仍然让我的呼吸在喉咙里哽咽。
David Rakoff's a writer in New York.
大卫·拉科夫是纽约的一位作家。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我自己制作的，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德也参与了。
Special thanks today to Mark Smith, creator of Chicago's semi-legendary Poetry Slam. Our Poultry Slam is named in tribute to it and to him. The title in no way is intended to demean or denigrate poultry. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天特别感谢芝加哥半传奇诗歌大放送的创始人马克·史密斯。我们的“禽类大放送”是为了向它和他致敬而命名的。这个标题绝无贬低或诋毁家禽的意思。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes listening to our program this way.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他这样描述收听我们的节目。
You really, I think, fall into a bit of an existential crisis. Like, what the hell am I doing? I really think I'm going to throw up.
你真的，我想，陷入了某种存在主义危机。就像，我到底在做什么？我真的觉得我要呕吐了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。